ein Tipp für alle die gerne starke Haare
möchten glänzende Haare oder auch sagen
meine Haare sind mir gerade zu kurz ich
möchte sie einfach schneller lang
wachsen lassen und zwar zwei Dinge
Schwarzkümmelöl nimmt gerne ein
Teelöffel zu Beginn gewöhnt euch dran
und nimmt dann gerne einen Esslöffel am
Tag ich nehm s jeen Abend vom Schlafen
gehen ich empfehle es aber immer nach
einer Mahlzeit einzunehmen plus die
beiden sind ein absolutes Dreamteam
gerstengraskapseln wenn ihr die beiden
Bioprodukte in Kombination nimmt dann
werden eure Haare sprießen sie werden
dick sie werden glänzend sie werden
wunderschön wie gesagt hier ist Biotin
unter enthalten und super super super
tolle Nährstoffe für die Haare und
Gerstengras ist ein absoluter Glow
Booster nicht nur für die Haut sondern
eben auch für die Haare also die beiden
in Kombination dankt mir später Leute
ist der absolute Hammer ich lasse euch
den Link dazu gerne mal im Profil und
ihr könnt mir auch super super gerne mal
euer Feedback geben wenn ihr das ein
paar Wochen durchgezogen habt ich zeig
euch jetzt auch noch meine Haare ich
färbe sie wirklich regelmäßig und sie
sind so dick und sie fallen mir toll tou
tou nicht aus